[Aplausos]
[Música]
tras las elecciones de octubre de 2019
en las que mauricio macri terminó su
presidencia con una palita que ni el
mismísimo rocky balboa hubiera sido
capaz de propinar el día 10 de diciembre
alberto fernández fue finalmente
investido presidente y tras él cristina
fernández de kirchner como
vicepresidenta tras cuatro años donde
parecía que algo podía cambiar la
argentina vuelve al punto de partida
ahora el nuevo presidente se enfrenta a
dos metas que parecen más complicadas
que conquistar el parís dakar con un 600
primero tratar de sacar al país de la
dura durísima crisis por la que está
atravesando y segundo consolidar su
poner frente a la sombra de su
vicepresidenta y es que amigos una nueva
guerra política parece estar fraguándose
en el seno del kirchnerismo
[Música]
por la locura de la argentina por la
locura nuestra alguna vez nos
distanciamos y alguna vez nos
reencontramos y nos reencontramos
sabiendo que no había diferencias
centrales entre nosotros
[Música]
y esto esto es lo que nos lleva a
hacernos algunas preguntas cuáles han
sido las primeras medidas que ha tomado
fernández tras su llegada al poder cuál
es la hoja de ruta que ha fijado el
nuevo presidente para tratar de sacar a
la argentina del pozo servirán todas
estas medidas de algo que futuro pinta
que tendrá el país gaucho atentos
[Música]
una herencia envenenada
y si sé que esto es algo propio de
políticos pero amigos no podemos empezar
la casa por el tejado muchísimas
personas me pidieron que hiciera una
cadena contando el estado en que había
encontrado el país y no lo hice creo que
es más constructivo hacerlo y si
queremos analizar la tarea que fernández
tiene por delante y lo primero de todo
para ser justos es tener claro qué país
se ha encontrado y la verdad es que el
escenario que se encuentra el nuevo
presidente no es precisamente el de un
relajado viaje en globo por las costas
de bora bora ni de lejos
alberto fernández se ha encontrado uno
de los peores escenarios que un político
podría imaginar ya os hemos hablado de
ello en un montón de vídeos que os dejo
en la descripción pero sólo tres datos
para situarnos y no perdernos en esta
especie de carrera hacia el abismo
[Música]
primero en 2019 la inflación ferro por
encima del 50% una cifra que equivale a
más de 10 años de inflación en un país
normal segundo la economía argentina
está en recesión una de las mayores
recesiones económicas del mundo con
algunos sectores cayendo ojo más de un
10 por ciento tercero el dólar que
comenzó 2019 en 42 pesos terminó el año
a un tipo de cambio de casi 80 pesos en
el mercado libre
tal y como veis un desastre mayúsculo
total y absoluto precisamente por estos
resultados es por los que mauricio macri
recibió uno de nuestros anti premios
2019 y es que amigos el gradualismo de
macri fue tan gradual que algunos aun lo
están buscando
y el único resultado que logró fue una
colosal pirámide de deuda porque al
final del gradualismo consistió
básicamente en eso no recortar el gasto
público y hacer pequeños ajustes que
permitieron atraer más inversión y así
hacer crecer la economía de esta forma
el peso de la deuda pública sobre el pib
se reduciría con el paso de los años
mientras tanto solventarían el decir
público con deuda
[Música]
y eso eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió
el gasto público bajo tres puntos en
términos de pib del 24 al 21 por ciento
mientras la estructura del estado seguía
creciendo y creciendo tal y como podéis
ver en este gráfico año tras año el
déficit público no paró de crecer
[Música]
una diferencia entre ingresos y gastos
que se pagó con deuda lo que creó un
enorme globo de deuda pública que al
final reventó obligando a argentina a
echarse otra vez en manos del fmi
[Música]
vamos que al final tal y como muchos
analistas económicos y políticos han
defendido la gran diferencia entre el
kirchnerismo y el macrismo fue una
cuestión más de forma que de fondo
porque las políticas eran prácticamente
las mismas y es que amigos no importa el
partido los políticos argentinos parecen
compartir un mismo lema más impuestos
más gasto más controles y así una y otra
y otra vez
[Música]
y la verdad es que a la vista de los
resultados pues la verdad es que no está
nada pero quien nada claro qué demonios
es exactamente lo que busca vamos los
recursos destinados a lo que se denomina
gasto social vemos que desde 1983 cuando
retornó la democracia hasta 2018 los
recursos destinados al llamado gasto
social aumentaron 10 puntos porcentuales
del pib y la pobreza no deja de crecer o
se mantienen niveles muy elevados
roberto cachanosky ya lo veis con macri
el gasto social alcanzó cifra récord al
tiempo que también se disparó en la
pobreza
según el observatorio de la deuda social
de la universidad católica argentina la
pobreza en argentina llegó al 48% y es
la más alta de la década estos índices
implican que 16 millones de argentinos
viven en la pobreza y 36 millones en la
indigencia para que os hagáis una idea
hoy en este país nos encontramos con
unos 8 millones de trabajadores que
pagan impuestos para sostener a 20
millones de personas que directa o
indirectamente reciben un cheque del
estado ya sea a nivel nacional
provincial o municipal y así claro pues
no se puede
[Música]
pero digámoslo de otro modo tiene en su
sano juicio invertiría un solo dólar en
un país con las características que
hemos visto es amigos y esa es la
cuestión a la que se va a tener que
enfrentar este nuevo gobierno pero el
momento pensáis que estoy exagerando
pues fijaos por ejemplo en esta
radiografía que ha elaborado la
asociación del contribuyente más de la
mitad del precio de un automóvil en
argentina son impuestos
y ojo porque están hablando de coches
medios fabricados y vendidos en el país
porque si hablamos de coches importados
y de alta gama los impuestos se disparan
aún más y con ellos evidentemente el
precio de los coches de esta forma un
coche de alta gama en argentina puede
llegar a costar 3 veces más que en eeuu
y más del doble que en españa países
donde los coches que se venden por
supuesto también tienen impuestos
[Música]
y eso amigos es entre otras cosas lo que
explica que en argentina comprar un
coche moderno como los que podemos
encontrar en cualquier país del mundo
desarrollado sea algo prácticamente al
alcance de muy pocos
pero eso eso no es todo también podemos
echar un vistazo al carrito de la compra
según el instituto argentino de análisis
fiscal más del 40 el 40 por ciento del
precio de una canasta básica de
productos alimentarios y bebidas no
alcohólicas corresponde a impuestos
[Música]
pero llegados a este punto de las
preguntas que podemos hacernos son ante
semejante panorama qué medidas ha tomado
fernández qué camino ha escogido pues
atentos
[Música]
yo les digo ya el pasado lo recordemos
para no repetirlo porque el tiempo que
se inicia es un tiempo distinto
el rumbo del nuevo gobierno
amigos ante el programa que hemos visto
con una argentina ahogada por la tercera
tasa de inflación más alta del planeta
con una economía en caída libre y una
enorme deuda nacional qué medidas habrá
tomado fernández habrá acaso decido
meter la tijera para acabar con el
déficit público habrá apostado por
aprobar incentivos para las empresas
para que éstas inviertan en el país pues
no exactamente
eso sí el nuevo gobierno ha aprobado un
duro durísimo ajuste tal vez mayor del
que muchos hubieran esperado el problema
es que una vez más este ajuste no afecta
al sector público
mientras el sector privado se va a
llevar un mazazo considerable hay ahí
hay lo público no se toca ni el gasto
administrativo ni el gasto político ni
el gasto burocrático se van a tocar lo
más mínimo
pero un momento en qué consiste
realmente este ajuste pues amigos si os
parece echemos un vistazo a las
principales medidas
[Música]
los que abrazamos la causa del peronismo
hemos llegado para hacer la voz de los
que no tienen voz
[Música]
a los que no lo quieren
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo primero es que van a subir los
impuestos se suben tipos aumentan las
retenciones a las exportaciones
agropecuarias que es una especie de
impuesto a la exportación en un sector
muy relevante en argentina y muy
importante no se van a actualizar los
montos no imponibles de los impuestos de
ojo porque esto último en un país con
una inflación de más del 50 por ciento
es algo que supone una mordida fiscal
enorme para los contribuyentes con menos
ingresos
[Música]
sí y veréis vamos a explicarlo en todos
los países los impuestos especialmente
los impuestos que recaen sobre las
personas suelen tener un mínimo exento
de tal forma que sigan las - de una
determinada cantidad pues no pagan
[Música]
pues bien en argentina no actualizará la
inflación este mínimo va a suponer un
buen golpe para muchas personas fijaos
imaginad por ejemplo es un ejemplo el
caso de un autónomo o un profesional que
tiene sobre sus ingresos un mínimo
exento de un millón de pesos de tal
forma que todo lo que supere esa
cantidad tributa
[Música]
pues bien como la inflación es de más
del 50% supongamos que sus ingresos han
aumentado el pasado año un 30 por ciento
hasta 1.300.000 pesos realmente este
profesional es más pobre que el año
anterior sus ingresos han aumentado
menos que la inflación es decir va a
poder comprar muchas menos cosas
[Música]
sin embargo amigos ahora además tendrá
que pagar impuestos sobre esos 300 mil
pesos que exceden el mínimo exento con
lo que aún será mucho más pobre y podrá
comprar aún muchas menos cosas
pues bien eso es exactamente lo que va a
ocurrir en argentina- tipos impositivos
más altos y un mínimo exento que no se
actualiza supone más presión fiscal
[Música]
pero ahí ahí no termina todo
otro de los sectores que van a pagar
duramente el ajuste van a ser los
jubilados dada la enorme inflación el
gobierno de macri estableció una especie
de ajuste semestral para que los
pensionistas no perdieran tanto poder
adquisitivo pues bien el nuevo
presidente ha decidido congelar esa
actualización durante 180 días para
todos los jubilados que cobran más de
250 dólares mensuales y dada la enorme
inflación que existe en el país eso va a
suponer una pérdida de poder adquisitivo
muy importante vaya todo un rejonazo a
la cartera de los jubilados
y seguimos para bingo también se han
elevado los tipos del impuesto sobre
bienes personales que es algo así como
un impuesto a la riqueza aunque claro
estamos hablando de argentina y en este
país la ley considera ricos a todas las
personas que tengan bienes por más de 30
mil dólares 30 mil dólares de locos
pero tal vez de todas las medidas la que
más controversia ha generado es la nueva
política respecto al dólar amigos el
gobierno de fernández ha establecido un
recargo del 30 por ciento para todas las
personas empresas que quieran ahorrar en
dólares o sencillamente quieran comprar
productos o servicios en el exterior es
lo que se conoce como el dólar solidario
[Música]
de esta forma aunque el tipo de cambio
oficial está en torno a los 60 pesos por
dólar si quieres comprar dólares para
digamos viajar al exterior o para
importar una cámara de fotos y el canje
que te van a aplicar va a ser de más de
80 pesos por dólar vamos algo así como
que quieres comprar cosas de fuera
viajar o invertir en el extranjero pues
paga por villanos y así están las cosas
terribles
y aún más por si esto no fuese
suficiente en la cantidad de dólares que
puedes comprar oficialmente está
limitada a 200 dólares por persona y mes
así que si quieres más te vas a tener
que ir a cambiar el dinero por la calle
es decir en el mercado negro
[Música]
vamos a ver realmente creéis que esta es
la mejor forma de atraer inversión y
hacer crecer los negocios en la
argentina no pinta bien
es verdad que con estas medidas de
ajuste lo que el gobierno quiere es
trasladar a los mercados internacionales
la idea de que la argentina quiere pagar
de que va a pagar sus deudas y así poder
renovar los créditos e incluso obtener
más financiación internacional
el problema amigos es que si no se toca
el gasto público y se castiga aún más a
la economía privada argentina corre el
riesgo de ahogarse
[Música]
la situación no es fácil eso está claro
pero oye tal vez los políticos podrían
empezar el ajuste dando ejemplo no os
parece fijaos en este cálculo que ha
elaborado roberto cachanosky a partir de
los presupuestos de 2019
[Música]
en fin amigos así están las cosas por la
argentina el gobierno de alberto
fernández ha empezado su mandato
aplicando un duro un durísimo ajuste un
ajuste que va en la misma línea de
siempre será caso que en la argentina
los políticos no saben hacer nada
diferente en visual política estaremos
muy atentos a los acontecimientos de
momento si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like suscribiros a visual político
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
nos abrazamos la causa del peronismo
hemos llegado para hacer la voz de los
que no tienen voz para darles derechos a
los que no lo tienen
[Aplausos]